تطور النهائي المشاهدين تشهده انظمه
الذكاء الاصطناعي لكنه يبدو كما نجح مكلل
ايضا بالخوف حتى بالنسبه لقاده قطاع
التكنولوجيا الذين باتوا ينظرون اليها
بتوجس وكان الروبوتات قنابل موقوته اما
الملياردير
الامريكي فكان قد عبر عن رايه قائلا ان
الذكاء الاصطناعي يوترني بشده وفي هذا
الصدد ومع اصدار شركه اوبن اي اي المدعومه
من مايكروسوفت النقاب عن الاصدار الرابع
من تطبيق تشات جي بي تي وجه باحثون رساله
صادره عن معهد
وقع عليها اكثر من الف شخص من ضمنهم ماسك
يحضرون فيها من المخاطر الجسيمه على
المجتمع والانسانيه لانظمه الذكاء
الاصطناعي يدعون فيها الى التوقف لمده سته
اشهر كامله عن تطوير انظمه انظمه اقوى من
روبوت الدردشه
مؤكدين ان مطوري الذكاء الاصطناعي يخوضون
سباقات خارج نطاق السيطره لتطوير ونشر
عقول رقميه اكثر قوه لا يمكن لاحد حتى
المطورين انفسهم من فهمها او التنبؤ بها
او حتى التحكم بها بشكل موثوق الرساله
مشاهدينا شددت الرساله التحذيريه على انه
يجب تطوير انظمه الذكاء الاصطناعي القويه
فقط عندما نكون واثقين من ان اثارها ستكون
ايجابيه وان مخاطرها ستكون تحت السيطره